hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm jerry so
everyone has been telling me about this
thing called power slash rangers
literally everyone all eighty thousand
four hundred and fifty nine mm power
rangers was the [ __ ] Vulcan skull oh
yeah but they made the show I mean Chi
Chi no they made the show they were the
actual creators of the television series
in Japan originally what then those
white guys came over and they said we
should put this in America in our native
tongue that's not that's I know but
Tommy was cool
Tommy was rad Jason any dude who as a
combination knife slash flute is cool
yeah Kimberly how could you not jerk off
to that Pink Ranger tell me jerk to see
that Pink Ranger I don't think I ever
did
you should totally look back on like
photos online
I was watching Karen just to think I was
wasn't doing that yeah and the Yellow
Ranger was a hot asian chick good times
good times your Duff Power Rangers I
know is the Blue Ranger whenever we
chose Rangers all right so we're gonna
review this short film first we're gonna
watch it well yeah we're just gonna do a
short film reaction and the camera cuts
every 12 minutes so there's gonna be a
point where it just randomly cuts and we
pick it back up
that's cool
that's really cool
when two empires declare war - ibises
your serenity worthless we were children
- to fight an intergalactic war against
an enemy we never met let's stop
pretending our sides but I'm on my way
last night
ten dollars embarrassed
[ __ ] isn't under code I just wait a
minute is that James fanner
flight which is to do today before you
do did you really wait until we were
discounted master and when accept the
Machine entire integrated of Technology
in our society you're the freedom equip
done he stabbed us in the back
I followed the only Woolworths father
Aetna structure made sure I was on the
winning side which is why I'm sitting
here in your chain wheelchair look like
Tron Tron company you were never really
were to us
thank you thought that weaponizing means
training in to kill them turned out so
ugly for so many of them we were a team
we fought for each other you know
progestogen every movie in the future
has that chase
Jesus what about you're married to a
warning that's
let's go
anything peddling false hope to fact it
wasn't up to scratch that itch whoa did
you know enjoying the sea empire so
hungry from now will be volunteer to
help us sweep up whatever resistance put
here we go program boy boy boy boy huh
common you know program Hunter Kasich EJ
job today is to get on a little D just
find the exact same role they played in
True Blood not aging up
oh come on
hi
ah
he probably could use the help
whoa
most people play the odds definitely
rare see did through the line extensions
ingredients whoa it's tough seeing your
friends murdered one by one come on I
got more of a comment especially if I
want to be [ __ ] it
think about leavin a time in the
fighting instance many portrayed her
switch sides mami dragged a terrible
losses following that lots again is just
[ __ ] between sign I'm glad I'm gonna
strip-search what about the machines at
least eight system
Tommy's always good
[ __ ] its today Tommy tative is really
Cranston alright yeah it's alright I
think we almost on lighting the [ __ ]
tent to raise the level of synergy with
adrenaline month we will be mass
producing our state your blade blaster
weapon within this award one point six
trillion euros so give you you're out of
your mind
Tommy didn't kill any of us he's a
ranger you just forgot why do you think
they gave his powers to kids because we
were the only ones who get to story at
six
put your [ __ ] together and stop thinking
for yourself for once in your life
you're not a little girl anymore
now where's Tommy don't [ __ ] yourself
I believe the interrogation officer
Victor defending simple with the ring
for being hello do we know I get the
technology the machines they always I
told you I tell myself well that's why
every move we make makes foot chase
well the government was negotiating the
treaty we were very Mauro
they complemented and he was gone
like in those years had a baby with the
Shah challengers
to improve things are never wrong little
is exactly what you know really just
objective never gauges of ladies you it
yes
Oh
she died
james van der beek Oh Rhoda
I did Bree Olson was in that for a
moment and she's [ __ ] hot uh dad that
was [ __ ] awesome dad
I dug the [ __ ] out of that pretty cool
Oh much money today spend is bet [ __ ]
alone how did they get the money for
this well james van der beek probably
still has some of that money yeah I
guess so you know when he got killed it
was like he got shot and dawson's she
yes it's the closest I could get what I
was watching this whole video
no okay as much as I loved credit the
opening sequence legit legal it is so
good when you seen the Rangers you're
already getting like a great first
glimpse as to like oh wow this really is
a totally different world and tell them
they're going for you oh yeah I mean
it's it's like gritty and nasty and then
with the Megazords fighting each other
that was [ __ ] sweet sure look straight
and transformers would work perfectly
for this world why me this is Michael
Bay's transformers like yeah like it
basically is like let's take
transformers and turn it into I mean
metrics let's take Karen in turn to a
gritty ass action movie and all it needs
is just the rain fight choreographers
yeah because like the one thing that
kind of disappointed me a little bit was
the fight scenes I felt could have been
a little better like I thought they were
cool like I thought they were cool
because I was like so into this story
but at the same time like especially
when Zach yeah the black Ranger was
[ __ ] up everyone oh I felt that like
it looked a little slow and very crafty
niz begging for some kind of you know
like zealot style yeah [ __ ] brutal
fight I mean it's still good action it's
decent but I felt that could have been
more I'm going from the beginning though
and you see that you see the setup it's
cool because this story they still tell
it in a way like they kind of took like
the watch
approach with it they they tell what it
was they took the watchman approach with
it as all the heroes are being killed
off its Watchmen Kill Bill the Raiders
like those are the that's what this new
this trans no it's re perfect it works
for this it works for what they're going
for like if they're trying to get like
an actual movie out of this that would
be pretty sweet because this is over
like a million views already so like it
would be sweet although I'm worried it
would give me a headache well I felt
like this was just a short film of what
could be a fee yeah I like the
interrogation sequences I thought that
was know I like everything it's just so
it's just so every moment and it has to
be like I get it but like every every
moment is so in-your-face and so already
and so that color palette like well they
have move yeah I think Power Rangers was
a little extreme in the bright side so
they had to go a little extreme in the
dark so scampi yeah but that but it
makes sense it's like they're also
having fun with it would like playing
with cliches you know it's like this
isn't exactly original hey you know cuz
i know cuz it's everything it's all
tribute you know that's yeah that's why
it does kind of remind me in the sense
of Kill Bill
because Tarantino most of his work is
him paying tribute to something yeah so
like that's what I felt like with Tommy
how he was like the guy living on the
streets now yeah no one can find Tommy
anymore he was our leader
it's a hermit but he can sneak anywhere
yeah
undetected including this impenetrable
fortress were interrogating you yeah the
guy who played him uh he's alright I
mean I really thought he was just doing
his Christian Bale yeah and he said who
are you
that is an exact way abbulu he said who
are you in the interrogation scene ended
with the Joker and it sounded exactly
the same yeah but other than that I mean
it wasn't that bad I mean really this is
all james Van Der Beek and Katee
Sackhoff that's Katee Sackhoff right and
I like to jag off the Katee Sackhoff you
know I mean it was better than the first
was better than awesome cheap much much
better than does she but Katee Sackhoff
guy
your name seriously Katy is this a
Sackhoff Katie Hasselhoff is not the
greatest in this though like fine I
thought like it was uh like you know
what Jesus and her because over on the
top but he's committed so is she she is
over I felt like she was holding back I
didn't think anybody ain't nothing in
this thing is holding back I felt like
what point of this I had no one's
holding I know I felt like she was going
out there but I felt like there was
still a part of her that was eliminating
herself I don't see it
let's get her on the phone and ask yeah
Katie Katie are you limiting yourself
were you only giving us a sneak peek at
what you're Kimberly would be like I
like how Jason and Kimberly got married
and it looks straight out of like Kill
Bill meets Friday Night Lights or Sarge
exactly it's Kill Bill but if instead of
bill is just turtle yeah like you so
bulk and skull shut I was like that
guy's straight it's it's [ __ ] turtle
from Entourage there's no way those two
dudes if there's him dudes they were in
junior high high score whatever powers
took what like those dudes not become
badasses I mean I kind of wish that we
got to see the Red Ranger just a little
bit Ranger was like the [ __ ] you mean he
Red Ranger was the star before Tommy
came around Jason is the Red Ranger
that's something I would have liked to
seen a snippet of instead him just me in
the car I get shot
it's intense moment though he has like a
ranger who really gets to be arrangers
is Zach yeah
well no that was the one bummer to me
about this thing is like was it what's
their conic
are they gonna go with this if they make
a movie because like all the Rangers
just died yeah but all dead now
we didn't even get to see Trini oh she's
just in a coffin like and we only see
Billy from like a crime I would I would
have liked to seen one fight scene where
they all fight together yeah that would
have been cool like some flashback of
them all fighting I miss the beginning
but kind but like less with him he okay
like it's cool the way it begins but
like to see that fight actually be like
a fight in there together yeah
I think Billy's a little too sexy now
see I was neither nerd
yeah the glasses but it kind of makes
sense that he'd become rich cuz it's
like the Mark Zuckerberg oh no he'd
totally become like a rich entrepreneur
but but I just don't think he would
become that what is he come Jane
Christian great yeah I mean he might be
[ __ ] up but yeah he's he's so sexy way
I know when Jason got shot I was like oh
[ __ ] that drew me off I wasn't expecting
a Power Ranger just get annihilated
right before my eyes
I like when Zach does [ __ ] go cakey
yeah it's like this is ghoul this is
like you make sense for some reason cuz
cocaine makes you like so jacked up like
I guess yeah I mean it was a little bit
like oh they made the black guy have
[ __ ] and cocaine like oh holy he at
least at least made him the [ __ ] though
I mean yeah he's the one who's sleeping
with two [ __ ] yeah it's just a
questionable choice any guy who's a race
relation any guy who can get two well we
don't know if they're hookers are
probably [ __ ] we picked up at the club
or some [ __ ] I'm fine you don't know if
you bought them if you bought them then
it's cliche but if you happen to just
come home with them this is like Zach
lives in a bad video like yeah yeah I
kind of agree like oh the black guy
lives in a pod hey I like where they're
going with the story a love triangle
yeah well Marcy why yeah cuz they're
both the two to three are dead already
yeah but ya know but I still liked what
they were doing with that like oh yeah
oh it's because it was like a love
triangle situation yeah and they're
making it like a really intense version
word like she was probably cheating on
Jason dude yeah she's gonna just dick
behind his back and I mean that was that
was that was in the show I was like oh
no mister whose can really gonna be with
I heard she only did anal with Tommy but
never with her husband Jason from who
james Van Der Beek it was cool to see
james van der beek to a sore fight i
feel like that's the whole reason he
wrote this was because he was like this
would be my chance to show off my
fighting skills does he is you know
fighting I don't think they practice
kendo Orson I he might he looks like one
of those Kodak inertia will take up some
random martial art got off of Dawson's
Creek and decided to take up Marshall
become a muy Thai fighter anyway guys
thanks so much for telling us that video
was out there's peer ad that was
definitely well work this is a special
episode this fund it's a special like 45
minute episode of our long history you
guys that's pretty good if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects and jerry has a playlist on
this channel called reasons to jerry
where he does movie reviews in his car
jacks off in the middle of the video
yeah you jack off flavor your butthole
oh i don't even know how you record if i
ever done I understand he keeps a phone
on the dashboard like it's on the stand
so it's okay that doesn't justify it I
mean I I don't know what video I use I I
don't think you wanted people to see the
video I saw no no I think not I don't
think I wanted to see the video I saw
yeah why would you do this to me did you
put the camera there are you admitting
that you play with your puddle no no no
no that's a one-way street all right I'm
not I'm not down really for me it's it's
like a three way street I got [ __ ]
free well you don't have fun in butthole
city because like if you fade the you
know the Tollbooth in advance you get a
highway Express there you know I mean
not Amos scissor or not my jam
mmm not down with it with brown well you
just don't take a lot of fiber that day
awesome